Hello everybody,
thanks for taking some time and peeling off of your expo
expeditions to sit down.
If you're anything like me, you've walked about 20,000
steps in the last few days, so sitting is probably a,
a welcome, uh, repar.
Uh, so let's jump in.
Today I'm gonna talk to you a little bit about Red Panda
for those of you who are not familiar. Uh, for those
of you that have experience in the streaming
world, this,
we're not talking about Netflix streaming and videos,
this is streaming data and data movement throughout
organizations, so we'll educate you there.
Uh, we'll get into the cross sections of AI
and streaming and where we've seen our
early research,
uh, find intersections that we think can be
very useful when you're adopting AI into
organizations.
Uh, we'll do, we'll actually dig into some architecture,
so we'll try to keep it high level, but for the people
that have experience at the infrastructure level,
we'll actually talk a little bit about how we deploy these,
uh, within ecosystems, within DPCs,
things like that.
Uh, lastly, try to provide you some actual practical
guidance, you know, I see a lot of use
cases thrown around, but try to give you some actual
actionable intelligence into how
we're integrating these, where to start, and where
to go.
So, uh, Red Panda as an
organization is traditionally in the streaming space.
Uh, for those of you who are familiar with Kafka,
we operate on top of the Kafka protocol,
and we help organizations like these move
data throughout their organizations. So this
could be,
uh, large financial services like
the New York Stock Exchange where we do very highly,
highly transactional workloads, moving
millions and millions as in uh 10
gig 10s of gig.
Bytes of seconds of data throughout their trading platforms.
This could also mean retailers where
we are
building systems that help them federate their
data and spread out session captures
throughout and essentially keep all this
data moving through durably, reliably,
and deployed
where their customers
typically deploy their workloads. This could be
self-hosted, this could be in any cloud or hybrid
nature. Now
this is just a quick look. This is
our typical form factor, so we have a
single binary, but this can be deployed
anywhere. We're cloud agnostic and this, this
includes self-hosted.
So this allows us to move throughout many
organizations and deploy across a wide spectrum
of use cases and verticals,
uh, all the way from very
security conscious organizations
that need very high restrictive. Class
zero data,
things like security, PII, PHI for
healthcare,
all the way to just typical retail data.
Now, uh, over the last few years, you can
see on the left and right, we've
taken great effort to expand
our ability to uh
extend into ecosystems,
pull data from source systems like typical
databases, MySQL, Postress, takeover
use cases like CDC.
Uh, in the middle there, we are providing you a durable
log, ways in which we are capturing
everything that's happening through those in an immutable, uh,
in an appended-only way, and then storing that
for safe access.
That'll come into play with where we're headed with
our AI products as well.
Lastly, on the right-hand side, you'll see
we can sync to. Most common solutions.
Uh, a lot of our customers need to pull data from
a very sparse, uh,
set of databases and microservices
and tools,
federate them out to another set of,
maybe Snowflake for analytics, maybe data bricks
to, to use Iceberg to do analytics, things
of that nature.
Uh, and this is really the foundation for which we're
building our AI products, uh, the, the
interconnectivity, the, the ability
to collect all these logs, and the ability to deploy
these anywhere.
Uh, as far as form factors, again,
all of this runs typically on,
for self-hosted bare metal, but then in
our cloud environments, this is all on top of K8s.
So we can scale this horizontally or vertically very
easy. It makes it easy for us to, to
handle DevOps and uh
acclimate to whatever the workloads we're, we're working
with. Now, let's
get into the AI and Agentic.
We've released uh our Agentic
data plane. This is built on top
of the, the form factor you just saw.
Uh, to give you a little bit of dive in, you're gonna have
agents, and the simplest
definition for agents is you have,
uh, a body that has intent in the form of
a prompt, it needs access to a model,
an LLM,
and then it needs a set of tools that you can use
to, uh, build, uh, complicated
processes or functions to get, you know, outputs.
So in our world, what you see in this box
here runs on AWS inside a private
VPC or it could be running, uh,
in your self-hosted, uh, data center.
And we provide all of these services that run
at runtime. So your agent is a separate
service that runs,
we have gateways that allow you access to
LLMs, uh, various, uh, types,
uh, and as you can see, we're not choosing a specific
vendor. We believe we're, we're not gonna
try to build your specialty agents. We, we think
that that's gonna be uh. Where you come in,
but we're coming from the infrastructure up. So
if you want to change out models, if you want access
to Bedrock, for example,
if you want access to OpenAI, you want
to use anthropic or cloud,
um, it doesn't matter to us because we think changing
those out is actually a superpower to allow
you to really dial in your agents.
Uh, as all this data is moving through, you
see all the lines, there's a lot of interconnectivity
and the streaming domain. We're used to handling all
of this disaggregation. We're used to
having to track down, get access
to all of these source systems that could be either
inside your organization or outside of it.
Uh, as you can see, there's some public internet traffic
here. We're used to egressing and ingressing
very sensitive information. We know how to do BPC
peering. We know how to do all this interconnectivity.
So we're baking this into how we approach AI and
how we integrate it.
Uh, lastly, you'll see at the bottom there,
all, all of these services are dumping to
a log or observability log,
uh, which would provide you the ability to do
things like replay through as agents are
being built, and we're already very good
at this. This is our bread and butter. This is something we've been doing
for the last 7 years. We know how to protect these,
we know how to distribute these logs, and we really know how
to make the best use of them in a very cost efficient
manner. So if we apply. That to agents and
all these gateways, we learned that agents
send out a ton of messages into
its entry system between each other
using AOA protocols,
every call it does to an MCP, for example,
and all of that can be written to these logs durably
for safekeeping and for replayability.
Uh, so, I, I keep hearing a lot
about what are the big challenges with this,
and where to start, and I hear governance, I
hear security, I hear access,
but really,
once we start digging into this, it becomes about
like trust first, is how
do you trust this entity that you're gonna give autonomy
to, uh, to make decisions, to
potentially trigger events that may,
uh, go off in your organization.
And the best way, you know, I'm, I'm
no, uh, I'm no writer, Ernest seem the way I
said it best, but the best way is to find out is,
is, is to extend some trust at first. So,
uh, I'll talk to you a little bit about the practical approach of how we
do that, how do we provide an environment where you can
give it some trust, see how these agents behave,
track all of this, uh, and then
start to figure out how do we implement this more
widely and how do we take it to production.
Uh, so first off, in our ADP
you can see we have a layered approach. So
in, in our thesis for how our products are
coming to fruition,
we have an action layer, which is where the agents
are actually taking action. These could be
security agents that are handling very uh
sensitive data.
This could be coding agents, which are very popular
right now and we see the heaviest use of, of course, it's
very approachable.
But then when you get some more, uh, esoteric
cases like, uh, manufacturing IOT
where you have different types Of agents that are
taking action.
They're all gonna pass through this data plan.
And if we can
provide a way for you to track all of
that, um,
uh, log all of that data, uh, responsibly,
and then, uh, also, uh,
collect all the reasoning layer access as
well. So every time an agent's calling out to an LLM,
uh, we, we want it to be passing through this single
plane, this data plane, and allowing you all the tools
to track that.
Uh, it's meant to really start to target,
I mean, common term we hear shadow AI.
If you've been around for a while, you've heard it as shadow
IT back in the day.
But we see a lot of this, people just going out, spinning things
up and running it,
and we believe that to trust your
organization, we start with a single plane, allow people
access, do proper authorization, authentication,
uh, do proper conventionaling, and people will
just use it through this plane. And that way we can actually
effectively track, effectively make policies
that make sense for your organizations.
Uh, so back to streaming and why we're layering
this in, streaming is already everywhere. We
stream for pretty much every single
vertical, and our use cases
span cybersecurity, a very sensitive
data, all the way to non-PII data,
including like hospitality data, loyalty
programs,
uh, analytics, things of that nature.
So where we're coming from is. Look
at how can we give you effective tools
to build into this existing infrastructure? Why
retool things that are when we already have
data flowing through an organization that's already
been authenticated with all of your end users, all of your
database admins have already created service accounts for
access to all of this?
How can we use this connectivity
to provide agents, uh, better context
and, uh, better ways to, to
operate?
Uh, in the streaming world, we already
have,
we, we understand that there's some primitives for,
for agents that don't apply, right? There are primitives
that we work with to move data very rapidly,
uh, throughout organizations, but that doesn't encompass
things like A2A
or MCP protocols. So how do we layer those
in? Well, we already have
very effective methods to distribute and do
asynchronous operations, right?
We already have this publish subscribe for those of you
unfamiliar with the streaming domain, where
we're publishing messages,
they're getting written to brokers, which is collecting this
immutable log, and then we can have any
number of subscribers subscribe to this. Information
to pull it and go anywhere else.
Now, if you really think about it, the same archetype
can be applied to agents. They're gonna become distributed
nature. They're going to
be sending messages. They're going to be subscribing
to many different services, tools, etc.
So we're applying the same principles that we've learned in
streaming to the, to the agent
deployments.
Uh, architecturally we look at, we already
know how to decouple services, and if you
think about agents, we have tools that are decoupled,
we have LLMs and reasoning that are decoupled,
but you still have these intersections in which you want to
collect all this information. You need to do tracing
on all those little pieces and you actually want the
outputs from all. All of that
stored durably and readily.
The last thing you want is a very high critical agent
to go down and be able to replay data,
understand what happened about it,
what happened to the data. Do you understand how to move
it and do DR responsibly? These are the
same concepts that we already do in streaming very well.
Uh, last thing is we're already built for real-time.
We, we help customers migrate from large
batch jobs all the way to very, very
fast, uh, real-time applications.
And there are cases in which,
uh, agents are good and bad for either batch or
streaming, but over time, we believe that
more agents are gonna be.
Uh, utilizing streaming,
uh, information either for event-driven architectures
to help trigger or kick off or to help
provide the most up to-date context because that's
one of the more powerful features that we've seen
for agents is
real-time context. Can we get it to them and can
it influence their decision making right now?
Uh, so in the problem space, we see,
you know, context building and maintenance being an issue,
uh, authorization, governance,
uh, we see auditing be an issue with
agents, how do you, can you audit these, replaying
and validation of agent actions, and,
and then multi-agent orchestration. And
again, these are all data streaming problems
that we've essentially solved in one capacity
that we're now augmenting to solve for agenttic
issues that we come across.
Uh, especially the governance and
replay, we already are at all these
intersections, as I said, we're collecting
all these tracing and we're storing it durably
and immutably. So you can't go in and alter
these logs. That way you have, uh,
already ingrained auditing pathway
that you can use.
And the last is a multi-agent orchestration.
We're gonna start to see these systems distribute very
widely.
Uh, and it's gonna be hard to track which agent
is doing what.
Well, it turns out we already do that in a capacity.
Most customers use us for logging activities
where we're collecting logs across maybe 15
different services, passing them through, filtering
them for them.
So we already have this framework set up to
be able to take, take this action from this like
DevOps infrastructure perspective.
Um, so just to hammer that home, uh,
in the context abroad, you can see here in this little diagram,
you know, I have agents deployed.
In our system, agents are deployed on K8s
and scalable within your VPC, so
we all have them running on pods, uh, but
they still need to get access out to databases. They're,
they are egressing your VPC out,
and we start to see a spider web create, right? All
these points of interconnectivity.
Um, our thesis is that
enforcement on that single data plane is
gonna be easier to manage from a DevOps perspective,
uh, and provides like uniformity. So you can actually
track, all right, how,
especially when you get to multi-agent orchestration, you have many agents
accessing the same MCP tools potentially,
or the same data sets.
Um, so,
so that is where we're really coming from with like a single plane,
a single data layer.
Uh, so,
just, just to summarize that, like we really
think that the intersection of data, that means
access, authentication,
uh, authorization to those sources, and this
includes MCP servers and just general connectors,
because you'll have both of your availability.
Uh, the AAI side of it means access to reasoning
models, this could be LLMs or this could be other
classification models,
and then governance, the ability to govern
all of this in one space, uh, and we want to
be at the intersection of that.
Now, let's talk about practical adoption. Like
how do you actually get this stuff into production?
Um, what we've seen when we speak with
customers, we get a lot of questions on
how do I get data access. Like, even if you're the
best at building, let's say, a
model context protocol and building MCP servers,
you still have to go to your database admin
to get access to this. They can't just spin it up
and say, go grab data.
Uh, which data can it get access
to? What, what is the user permission structures?
So it really starts with our organizational
conversations, like, talk to your infrastructure teams about
what data should be available. Your security
teams will know what are lower level
or non-class 0, class 1 data that
may be used to start testing these,
but that is the slowest piece. It's really not that
hard to stand up K-8s, get your services
running, and get connected. It's Really hard
to start working through how do I connect them? How
do I get data to this agent? Uh, is that
a database query through an MCP protocol?
Is that actually a connector doing a CDC
workload?
That piece is taking the longest, so I
actually advise people to start there, start asking,
where can I get access sooner and
what types of access can I give it.
Uh, on deployment, um,
we're recommending starting with secure
VPCs and private networking just as
a safe rail and safeguard, right?
This goes back to that trust component. You really don't want
your agent egressing and making decisions
out, especially on the open internet, when you're not
sure of its non-deterministic behavior.
So lock it down, log it to.
within your local VPC
and then until you really get a good understanding
of what the actions is taking,
how does the particular LLM behave,
uh, especially when you're changing the prompt
iteratively, because typically
when we're developing agents, you're doing it very quickly.
You're changing the prompt, seeing what the behavior is
and seeing if it matches your measurable criteria.
Uh,
lastly,
this is kind of antithetical to what I've seen,
but I see people searching for
new use cases and new things to solve with
agents, and I come from a
processing background, uh, and that's the use
case we'll dive into is IOT manufacturing.
When you really wanna automate something, you don't
start with a, an amorphous
thing that You don't understand, you should pick something
that you know already, that you already have
well documented steps for.
That way you can actually understand, OK,
is the agent behaving
in a manner that we already understand? Uh, let's
say, rather than take a, a really
crazy problem, try to throw it at it, start with
the actual document that has 30 steps in it
and see if your agent can replicate it.
Uh, that's much easier to track, much easier to implement,
uh, and, and really gives you a good starting point,
especially because you understand how to measure it.
Um, and number one question I get
when we're speaking to customers is, what are the use cases?
And it's like, well, let's start with something. Let's
augment a process and help one
person become 3 within your organization
by figuring out what are the processes they understand
very well.
Um,
so for us in
the streaming domain, we're targeting low latency
use cases because that's a strength of ours.
This, this doesn't mean that agents
can't be used for, uh, longer
runtime or more heavy deep
thinking, but if we're being realistic,
uh,
we like to look at. Ad tech manufacturing
gaming where
seconds matter and you want inferences coming
through agents and decisions being made quickly,
that's gonna help just drive value right sooner
so common, these are some of the common latency
domains today we're looking at manufacturing
is where I have a background and we'll look at a
use case so.
In a manufacturing example,
pardon my little arrows there, they're supposed to be going sideways.
Um, you have a lot of equipment on a factory
floor. Uh, it's a common use case where we're,
we're aggregating all this data through maybe a
protocol like MQTT. We're pulling it in,
and we're doing a factory management system,
and then we're doing an operational database that's,
that we're coalescing this data to.
So within this use case, where
could we deploy agents? Well, there's a couple of places.
Since red panda can run at the edge, we can run them
very closely to the machine equipment.
And common use case would be they're augmenting
a technician and helping guide them through a
process of, all right, uh, something happened at the
edge, uh, an agent has been monitoring
the stream and already has access
through maybe a vector store or maybe even
just raw text
about a given manual,
and, uh, a technician will physically
go stand there and be given information, and say, hey,
based on this information,
uh, here's the decision criteria or
the RCA you should work through to repair this
machine. Um, so that's like a
physical use.
Now, when we get more towards the operational
database side where we can have more agents
running,
there's where we can start to provide context. Things
like, uh, let's say
it's, it's, it's common to have multiple machines
of the same type. Let's say we have 50 of them, and
I install spare parts into one,
from a specific provider with a SKU.
Um, we already have systems in, in
place that can give you indicators
that a machine is failing, but what it can't
do is reason and think and say,
all right, we installed the same spare part
in two different machines.
Uh, I'm gonna go ahead and recommend you stop the
second machine that hasn't even displayed problems
yet on any of the telemetry metrics,
uh, and, and, and do remediation
based on knowledge that I gained through context, right?
And that could be just a PDF that was uploaded with their spare
parts, uh, when they did change of management.
So that's like one of the use cases
that actually makes sense to have
an agent that's running 24/7 that
has human in the loop and is helping you
uncover and, and, and stop
something from uh happening that would
actually, you wouldn't discover through just
traditional preventative maintenance,
uh, or traditional PID controllers.
So that's an actual just um
a bare bones use case, that gives you like an idea
of, of where you can deploy these that actually create
value.
So that's all I have for you. Thank
you. Really, I really appreciate you taking some time out.
Um, and if you need to talk to me that we don't have a
Q&A here, but I'll be at our booth, which is
right over there by the Sula DB booth if you have
questions about the session.
Thank you.